- Hello, and welcome to Fall
in Love with Jordan Mendoza
with Hannah Hart.
We're gonna answer the 36
Questions to Fall in Love
from the New York Times.
These are questions that studies say,
creates a sense of intimacy between people
and even makes them fall in love.
And we don't have that much time
so only you're gonna answer questions
and we're not gonna answer all of them.
- You're not answering the questions?
- No.
- So it's just, okay,
so I'm just gonna put myself out there.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's cool.
- So first question,
given the choice of anyone
in the world, with whom would
you want as a dinner guest?
- Honestly, I would say
probably Patrick Stewart.
I don't know, sometimes I just think that
Patrick Stewart might be my real dad.
So, that's why I'd like him to come.
- I just want to say, to check in,
I liked you when we were
just talking before this,
but I kind of like-like you now.
- Really?
- Yeah, is that weird to say?
- No, I mean, yeah man, that's great.
No, it's funny though,
because it's, you know.
- Next question, before
making a telephone call,
do you ever rehearse
what you're gonna say?
- Not really.
- Oh, I have like a big
crush on you. (laughs)
(Hannah snickers)
How do you feel about me at this point?
- My feelings remain
the same, oddly enough.
- Well, let's do the next
one and see where it goes.
- (laughs) Oh, I think I
know where it's gonna go.
It's gonna stay right here.
- Maybe in a relationship.
- I think we're gonna, (clicks tongue)
- If you could wake up tomorrow
having gained one ability or
quality, what would it be?
- I have such a fear of
the ocean, and so for me,
I feel like it would probably
be to breathe under water.
I think that's a really
realistic, good application.
- I just don't wanna label
things at this point.
But we're like, we're
definitely dating, right?
- Right now?
No, have you done this segment before?
- This is the first time,
but I think it's going
just so well and I am really excited about
where this is gonna go.
Take four minutes to tell
your partner your life story
in as much detail as possible.
We don't really have that much time,
so can you do it in 40 seconds?
- This is VidCon's ninth year.
I've been here seven,
no, eight out of nine.
- [Jordan] Oh, wow!
- Yeah, and that's pretty
much my life these days.
Everything else you can read in my memoir,
Buffering, Unshared Tales
of a Life Fully Loaded.
- I'd love to read it.
- Oh, yeah!
- And, I love you.
(Hannah gasps)
- Oh man, that's so fun.
I think you're great.
- Say it back?
- Say it back.
- Just...
- You know, I am gay.
I'm a lesbian.
- Love transcends all,
so I believe in love.
- Me too, but I'm also in a relationship
to be honest.
- I also am too.
And I bet she's open to anything.
And at this point, I'm
willing to say, "I'm all in."
And if you also want to be all in,
I think that's cool as hell.
And just say I love you to me.
(Hannah sighs heavily)
Do you have a secret hunch
about how you'll die?
- Hopefully not today.
- No.
- Okay.
- I would never hurt you, I
would hurt someone who hurt you.
If anyone's hurt you
before, I'll murder them.
And I'll make it hurt.
- (gasps) Oh!
- I'll make them feel it.
I'll press my thumbs into their eyes.
- I think that we've learned
a lot about you as well today.
Nobody else is alarmed.
- Share with your partner,
an embarrassing moment in your life.
- (clears throat) You
know, it's interesting
because I don't necessarily want to
become more vulnerable in this situation.
- Uh-huh, I feel like
you're pulling away from me.
Hannah.
- Oh, Jesus.
- Will you marry me?
- (sighs) Oh my god.
That's a no.
- Okay, so I guess we
end it with eye contact
for two to four minutes.
So let's just do that.
- (groans) Oh, man.
(clears throat) Ah, wow.
- This is about two to
four minutes, I bet.
Let's just do that.
- Okay.
- And we have a timer? Cool.
- Isn't that what this is?
- Alright, let's go.
- Okay.
(soft piano music)
- I can see you broke eye contact.
- You know--
- I'm not gonna read into that.
- Okay.
- But I think that's probably
about how much time we have.
- Yeah.
- Together, today.
- But, I feel like we're gonna be together
in kind of a forever
kind of way, personally.
So there you have it
guys, the New York Times'
36 Questions to Fall in Love.
I'm surprised it works.
I didn't believe in love before
this but (laughs) here I am.
Hannah has taken my heart, wow.
- You know, I have a self-help podcast.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, maybe you should check it out.
- I'd love to be on it, as a guest.